[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport ein schillernder familie
und das sind unsere themen heute
strengere regeln für ungeimpfte die
steigenden corona zahlen fachten die
diskussion über die rechte für menschen
mit und ohne impfung weiter an lernen
aus der katastrophe die politik berät
über ein besseres warnsystem und eine
engere zusammenarbeit der behörden und
bronze im slalom kam der augsburger
sideris tasiadis holt im olympischen
wildwasserkanal platz drei wir beginnen
mit corona die zahlen gehen auch
hierzulande wieder deutlich nach oben
binnen einer woche um 75 prozent
was also tun einen zwang zum impfen soll
es nicht geben weitere nachteile für
ungeimpfte aber auch nicht fordern
parteiübergreifend immer mehr politiker
und politikerinnen mehr zu dieser
diskussion gleich zunächst einige fakten
von thomas garcia geimpfte genesene
getestete sie sind rechtlich
gleichgestellt weitgehend beispielsweise
bei restaurantbesuchen oder bei der
rückkehr aus risikogebieten gleiche
rechte für die 3g nicht gleich ist das
restrisiko jemanden anzustecken
das ist bei geimpften erheblich
reduziert laut rk ii verhindern
impfstoffe infektionen um mindestens 65
prozent
mrsa sind wirkungsvoller und geimpfte
sind kürzer infektiös auch genießen die
nach vier wochen eine impfung bekommen
übertragen das virus weniger häufig bei
getesteten aber gibt es ein problem
fehleranfälligkeit der selbsttests vier
von zehn sind im schnitt falsch negativ
infektionen werden zuweilen unerkannt
weiter gegeben
pcr tests dagegen gelten als fast 100
prozent korrekt mit ihnen gilt getestet
gleich gesichert
fakt ist auch in deutschland wird jeden
tag weniger geimpft am 9 juni war der
höhepunkt der impfwelle rund 1,4
millionen menschen bekamen da eine
spritze seitdem geht es abwärts am
vergangenen mittwoch waren es mehr als
730.000 impfungen gestern allerdings ein
sonntag weniger als 120.000 wie
gegensteuern
die debatte über einschränkungen für
nicht geimpfte nimmt fahrt auf heike
slansky trotz heftiger kritik auch aus
den eigenen reihen kanzleramtschef brown
bleibt dabei bei steigenden
infektionszahlen im herbst könnten
getestete mit geimpft nun genesenen
nicht mehr gleich gestellt werden wer
sich nicht impfen lässt nimmt an der
pandemie weiter teile deshalb muss er
damit rechnen dass wir das er
regelmäßige tests braucht um am
öffentlichen leben teilzunehmen oder
eben das auch kontakt reduzierung noch
mal notwendig werden der druck auf
ungeimpfte wächst wenngleich die
bundesregierung eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ablehnt die fdp hält browns
vorstoß für verfassungswidrig geimpfte
getestete negativ getestet und genesen
von denen geht keine besondere gefahr
aus und deshalb über vielleicht die
maske im öffentlichen personennahverkehr
sind dann keine freiheits eingriffe mehr
gerechtfertigt tatsächlich genießen
jetzt schon geimpfte und genesenen mehr
rechte als ungeimpfte beispiel reise
rückkehrer aus risikogebieten keine
quarantäne keine tests licht keine
kontakt beschränkungen
wer bock ist für browns idee scholz geht
es um die kosten der schnelltests
spätestens dann wenn möglichst viele
geimpft sind und alle die möglichkeit
hatten sich impfen zu lassen
auch irgendwann das nicht mehr möglich
sein wird diese tests öffentlich zu
bezahlen
die wichtigste aufgabe ist die mobile
nimmt teams weiter zu finanzieren jedem
menschen ein impfangebot zu machen und
dann die nächsten schritt wenn das
geleistet worden ist darüber zu sprechen
dass in manchen bereichen eben leute die
geimpft sind dinge tun können und andere
nicht eine zu niedrige impfquote bei
steigenden infektionszahlen ein dilemma
das auf der nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz im
kanzleramt für viel stoff sorgen wird
hier noch der blick auf die genauen
corona zahlen das robert koch institut
registrierte 958 neue infektionen
innerhalb eines tages das sind 412 mehr
als vergangenen montag drei todesfälle
kann binnen 24 stunden hinzu die sieben
tage incidents liegt jetzt bei 14,3 in
frankreich liegen die infektionszahlen
höher als bei uns mit scharfen maßnahmen
wollte präsident makro dagegenhalten
jetzt hat das parlament einen kompromiss
verabschiedet
der sieht zwar weiter vor dass sich
beschäftigte im gesundheitswesen impfen
lassen müssen
anders als geplant droht ihnen bei
missachtung aber nur noch eine gehalts
sperre keine entlassung mehr
außerdem wird der gesundheitspass im
alltag immer wichtiger
ohne kommt man ab august weder in
restaurants noch in fernzüge in der
flutkatastrophe in deutschland haben
mindestens 179 menschen ihr leben
verloren
warum so viele hätte mehr oder besser
gewarnt werden müssen hat die
zusammenarbeit zwischen den behörden
funktioniert in einer sondersitzung
beriet der innenausschuss des bundestags
heute über konsequenzen für den
katastrophenschutz karl hinterleitner
berichtet
auch heute stehen teile des landes noch
unter wasser in rheinland-pfalz
nordrhein-westfalen wird schon
aufgeräumt in der politik wird jetzt
aufgearbeitet
vor der heutigen sitzung des
innenausschusses kann man stimmen aus
der spd die mehr kompetenzen für den
bund fordern bei großlagen dürften
kommunen und länder nicht allein
gelassen werden
deswegen muss der bund bei lagen die das
gesamte bundesgebiet betreffen oder die
länder überfordern würden alleine auch
eingreifen können da werden wir um eine
diskussion um eine verfassungsänderung
nicht herumkommen dem widerspricht der
innenminister vehement die
zuständigkeiten zwischen bund und
ländern seien richtig verteilt und ein
wert für sich für den katastrophenschutz
sind bei uns in deutschland seit
jahrzehnten die länder zuständig aber
anders bleiben
das halte ich für richtig das ist
genauso wichtig wie die föderale
struktur der sicherheitsorgane
und wer das verändert fügt der sache
schaden zu seehofer setzt sich für
bessere waren systeme ein sollen im
katastrophenfall neben sirenen und
rundfunkdurchsagen waren apps fürs handy
noch in diesem jahr zur verfügung stehen
außerdem ist ein gemeinsames
kompetenzzentrum von bund und ländern
geplant dass bei kritischen lagen
zusammenkommt die opposition ist all das
zu unverbindlich das ganze basiert
natürlich auf freiwilliger basis genau
so wie wir es jetzt auch beim
gemeinsamen terrorabwehrzentrum erleben
aber die probleme fangen halt eben
häufig dann anja wenn es halt eben zur
kritischen situation kommen und ich
prognostiziere dass das beim gemeinsamen
kompetenzzentrum sich ähnlich entwickeln
wird konkrete beschlüsse gab es heute in
berlin also kaum mehr der gute wille in
zukunft bessere zu kooperieren
eines hat die katastrophe auch wieder
gezeigt die große hilfsbereitschaft im
land allein mit der zdf spendenaktion
sind mittlerweile 43 millionen euro
zusammengekommen
wofür das geld gebraucht und eingesetzt
wird zeigen heike kruse und julia
schröter sie weiß nicht der wievielte
patient heute vor ihr steht bis zu 100
kommen jeden tag in die mobile
arztpraxis des deutschen roten kreuzes
in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler medizinische
versorgung auf rädern
denn die wassermassen haben
auch viele praxen vor ort zerstört die
mobile arztpraxis wurde aus spenden
finanziert die kosten 350.000 euro beim
schutt wegräumen in hitze und dreck
verletzten sich viele menschen die
kleinen wunden jetzt sind auch die wo
wir am meisten die befürchtung haben
dass da infektion entstehen können
deswegen bitten wir sie auch tatsächlich
herzukommen es gab auch ein aufruf zur
tetanus info die hilfe läuft auf vielen
ebenen das technische hilfswerk hat eine
behelfs fähre über die aa eingerichtet
auf mehreren kilometern die einzige
möglichkeit für fußgänger und helfer von
einem teil der zerrissenen stadt in den
anderen zu kommen schwersten
zerstörungen auch im ort in suhl mit
blick direkt auf die erlebte gisela
breuer mit ihrer familie erst vor knapp
einem jahr hatten sie das elternhaus
renoviert im untergeschoss sind jetzt
nur noch die banken mauern übrig im
ersten stock hat die familie die
katastrophe überstanden
von unschätzbarem wert die hilfe von
bekannten direkt danach
wir haben auch was wichtig ist das
denken übernommen weil wir gar nicht
mehr denken konnte weil wir wie in einer
blase lebten und die haben das
organisiert und wir haben den angefangen
mit einer schlamm raus zu tragen
die familie ist inzwischen bei freunden
untergekommen
weil man muss auch ein ruhepunkt finden
um herunterzukommen um mal wieder neue
kraft zu nehmen aber schlafen ist schwer
ganz schwer
jeden tag kommen sie zurück in ihr haus
und rappen tapfer was zu retten ist etwa
fotos erinnerungsstücke die jetzt erst
mal auf der wäscheleine hängen
irgendwann sagt gisela breuer soll ihr
zuhause wieder schön sein hobby pianist
in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler bobby in den
vergangenen tagen gab es immer wieder
auch kritik am krisenmanagement etliche
freiwillige helfer wurden weggeschickt
wie ist es heute
ja es gibt immer noch unglaublich viel
zu tun aber einiges wird jetzt zumindest
besser organisiert vergangene woche war
es ja noch so da sind ganz viele
privatfirmen mit schwerem gerät also
garten und landschaftsbauer schrottland
schrotthändler hierhin gekommen
auf eigene faust ii haben irgendwelchen
müll
aufgeladen und haben den zur deponie
gebracht das wird jetzt gesteuert der
krisenstab des kreises ahrweiler sagt
dadurch erreicht man mit der gleichen
anzahl an fahrzeugen dass die doppelte
menge an müll weggebracht werden kann
am wochenende haben ja ganz viele
private helferinnen und helfer die
straßen verstopft einfach weil alle mit
dem eigenen auto angereist sind
mittlerweile sammeln sich die helfer
außerhalb auf parkplätzen und werden
dann mit einem shuttle-service an die
orte gebracht wo sie gebraucht werden
also was das zusammenspiel von privater
und staatlicher hilfe angeht da geht das
geschieht jetzt ein stück weit mehr
miteinander und nicht wie vorher
nebeneinander dankeschön kriterien und
sie können den menschen im flutgebiet
weiterhelfen hier nochmal die angaben
zum konto das aktions dass das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
eingerichtet hat die iban lautet de 65
104 106 100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf
hochwasser weitere informationen finden
sie unter spenden punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 8 190 nach tunesien
dort tobt ein politischer machtkampf von
dem noch unklar ist was dahintersteckt
manche sagen putscht dazu andere
sprechen von überfälligen maßnahmen
lange galt tunesien als die
erfolgsgeschichte des arabischen
frühlings als einziges der betroffenen
länder hatte es 2011 den übergang zur
demokratie geschafft doch schnell machte
sich ernüchterung breit wirtschaftlich
lief es immer schlechter dazu kamen
korruption ständige regierungswechsel
und zuletzt mangelhafte maßnahmen gegen
die korona pandemie thomas walde den
ganzen tag gab es rangeleien vor dem
parlament in tunis abgeordnete die es
betreten wollten wurden von militär und
polizei daran gehindert
zuvor hatte der präsident den
regierungschef abgelöst und das
parlament suspendiert abgeordnete nennen
das einen putsch das ist der versuch die
verfassung außer kraft zu setzen und die
werte der republikanischen ordnung
tunesiens präsident karsai jetzt zeigte
sich inmitten von anhängern
er hatte sich ebenfalls auf die
verfassung berufen sie erlaube seine
entscheidung weil die eine unmittelbare
gefahr für den staat abwenden
der präsident der republik übernimmt die
exekutive gewalt mit hilfe der regierung
die durch an den neuen premierminister
angeführt wird den der präsident der
republik benennt in den vergangenen
wochen gab es an verschiedenen orten des
landes proteste gegen die regierung weil
sich die wirtschaftliche lage infolge
der korona krise weiter verschlechtert
hatte
so wurde unter anderem die auszahlung
von sozialleistungen verzögert ich stehe
seit 9 uhr hier und jetzt ist es 12 und
gucken sie sich doch mal die korona lage
an die krankenhäuser sind überfüllt
[Musik]
tunesien verzeichnete die höchste
infektionsrate afrikas es fehlt an
medizinischer versorgung und ein
impfstoff nach der corona und der
wirtschaft nun die staatskrise
bislang war tunesien stolz als einziges
land nach dem arabischen frühling eine
demokratie geworden zu sein
die kommenden wochen werden zeigen ob
tunesien eine bleibt deutschland können
nicht alles kompensieren sagte die
kanzlerin und meinte damit weitere
flüchtlinge aus afghanistan aufnehmen
mit dem abzug der internationalen
truppen verschärft sich die
sicherheitslage dort dramatisch die
islamistischen taliban sind auf dem
vormarsch haben weite teile des landes
unter ihre kontrolle gebracht
die zahl ziviler opfer steigt
zehntausende sind vertriebene im eigenen
land viele fliegen in den iran und
weiter in die türkei
von dort berichtet jörg brase sie haben
es geschafft durch iran über die grenze
in die türkei
es sind junge afghanische männer sie
wollen es erstmal allein versuchen
wollen die familien später nachholen
wenn sie in sicherheit sind vor den
taliban
ich will hier arbeit suchen in
afghanistan gibt es kein geld zu
verdienen dort gibt es nur die taliban
die verteilen waffen und fordern dass
wir für sie kämpfen dafür sind wir
geflohen
es drohe ein neuer exodus warnen
experten afghanen kombinierten tag ihr
ziel ist die türkei doch viele wollen
weiter nach europa migrationsexperte
murat erdogan fordert das eu türkei
flüchtlings abkommen neben syrischen
auch auf afghanische flüchtlinge
auszuweiten
wir müssen eine neue modelle entwickeln
diese modell ist natürlich gigantisch
ist die wichtigste vielleicht aber in
die welt ist nicht genug drin wir müssen
wirklich müssen schließlich langfristig
projekte nehmen und dann mit dem zug
etwas intensiver arbeiten
die türkische opposition kritisiert
jetzt schon ist könne einen deal geben
auf dem rücken der türkischen
bevölkerung
es heißt brüssel wolle der türkei ein
großes finanzielles hilfspaket anbieten
damit die afghanischen flüchtlinge nicht
in die eu gehen
das ist nichts als bestechung wir werden
uns einer zahl von 500.000 bis einer
million afghanischen flüchtlingen
gegenüber sehen die stimmung in der
türkei könnte kippen wenn zu den knapp
vier millionen syrern im land auch noch
afghanische flüchtlinge hinzu kommen wir
schauen noch mal auf die unwetter
hierzulande bei heftigen gewittern mit
starkregen und sturmböen sind gestern in
sachsen und bayern zwei menschen ums
leben gekommen
besonders betroffen war die region um
eglfing in oberbayern er hier gefallene
hagel lag teilweise bis zu einem halben
meter oben
bäume stürzten um und auch am nachmittag
gab es wieder unwetter wie hier im
enzkreis in baden württemberg keller
wurden überflutet und jetzt olympia
norbert dritter tag und dritte medaille
für deutschland sei dies zum dritten mal
aus bronze als ladung minute sideris
tasiadis hat sie im wildwasserkanal
harte kämpft hinter den konkurrenten aus
slowenien und tschechien
die zweite medaille für den augsburger
bei olympischen sommerspielen
im ziel entlädt sich bei sideris
tasiadis die ganze anspannung volles
risiko vom start weg die devise des
augsburgers im olympischen stange im
parcours braucht der 31-jährige all
seine erfahrung knie und im kanu muss er
auf engstem raum wellen und walzen
überwinden
einzig an tor 19 treibt das wasser weit
nach unten
danach profitierte adidas von der
wendigkeit seinem umgebauten kajaks und
holte nach silber 2012 in london neun
jahre später bronze in tokio platz zwei
geht an lukas rohan aus tschechien
olympiasieger wird der slowene benjamins
fc erfolg für die deutschen
beachvolleyballerinnen laura ludwig und
margareta koch nach der niederlage
gestern heute ein hart umkämpfter sieg
gegen zwei japanerinnen in zwei zu null
setzen
damit hat sich das deutsche duo direkt
fürs achtelfinale
nach der knappen niederlage
vorgestern im ersten vorrundenspiel
gegen spanien heute ein wichtiger sieg
für die deutschen handballer die dhb
auswahl gewann gegen argentinien klar
mit 33 zu 25 übermorgen geht es gegen
weltmeister frankreich und vize
weltmeisterin sarah köhler hat das
finale über 1500 meter freistil erreicht
die 27-jährige konnte als vorlauf
sechster problemlos das dritte final
ticket für den deutschen schwimm-verband
in tokio lösen muss sich aber für eine
bessere platzierung im entscheidenden
rennen am mittwoch weiter steigern
durch starke leistungen hatten die
deutschen turner das finale des
mannschafts mehrkampfs erreicht indem es
dann heute nicht so gut für das deutsche
quartett lief nur platz acht sie sind
mit großen erwartungen in den wettkampf
gestartet die für toner aus deutschland
doch ein rang in medaillennähe blieb aus
nur platz 8 zunächst ging alles glatt
andreas toba am sprung diesmal trat der
30-jährige auch ohne schwere
verletzungen an der held von rio 2016
hatte mit einem kreuzbandriss die
deutschen turner ins finale gebracht
doch trotz guter leistungen konnten er
und seine team kollegen wie hier lukas
pause am barren
gegen das starke russische olympische
komitee und den zweitplatzierten
gastgeber japan nicht mehr
entgegensetzen
vielleicht ein kleiner trost die toner
elite erreichte zum vierten mal seit
peking 2008 das mannschaftsfinale und
hier noch die goldmedaille des tages
errungen durch eine 13-jährige mit china
schreibt als erstes skateboard
olympiasiegerin geschichte die japanerin
setzten sich gegen eine ebenfalls 13
jährige brasilianerin und eine 16
jährige japanerin durch mein gott komme
ich mir halt vor acht norbert von jahr
fahren jetzt nach beckum im kreis
warendorf eine kleine stadt schreibt
geschichte so sieht es aus deutschlands
erstes haus aus dem 3d drucker 160
quadratmeter auf zwei etagen und das
geht so ein riesiger beton drucker trägt
wie bei einer torte schicht für schicht
den beton auf und wenn den bewohnern mal
nach grundlegende veränderung ist
schmeißt man den drucker einfach noch
mal an
jetzt kommt eine ganze riege von
unwetterwarnungen der deutsche
wetterdienst warnt aktuell vor schweren
gewittern mit starkregen in teilen von
schleswig holstein baden württemberg
bayern und sachsen und morgen kündigen
sich wieder unwetter an
mehr dazu hat gleich erst intern bettina
schausten freut sich auf sie im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn und hier hat
morgen diana pareigis premiere
danke für ihr interesse alles gute ihn
und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter weitere unwetter kündigen sich an
und zwar mit einem tief über den
britischen inseln
es zieht über den ärmelkanal und schiebt
hier dieses wolkenband mit regen zu uns
und dazu eben auch hagel und dieser
regen der wird dann ziemlich intensiv
werden teils in kurzer zeit größere
mengen so auch dann auch im süden
deutschlands
schauen wir auf die nacht gibt es noch
gewitter im osten und im südosten die
lassen allmählich nach und da wo die
schauer verschwinden bildet sich
teilweise nebel
ja und im nordwesten da gibt es
ebenfalls noch etwas regen temperaturen
sinken auf 12 grad an den alpen und 18
grad im nordosten deutschlands
morgen am vormittag kündigen sich die
ersten schauer von westen heran
ansonsten gibt es viel sonne vor allem
im osten aber zum nachmittag ändert sich
das ja kaum heftige gewitter auf und in
den abendstunden kann das auch dann um
wettermäßig werden genauso im süden
deutschlands und das bei temperaturen
bis 29 grad im osten und 20 bis 24 grad
in den westlichen landesteilen
am mittwoch gibt es weitere heftige
gewitter vor allem im norden und im
süden deutschlands bei temperaturen bis
27 grad oder ab donnerstag wird das
allmählich ruhiger und damit ein schöner
abend